-Well, guys, it seems like
there's so much
going on right now.
Last night, President Biden
delivered the
State of the Union,
this Sunday is the Super Bowl,
Valentine's Day
is next week -- yeah --
and Taco Bell just announced
a new Mexican pizza
that's four times bigger, called
the Big Ass Mexican Pizza.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There's a lot to go over,
so let's just jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
First up, last night's
State of the Union address.
Biden spoke to the nation about
his goals and achievements.
For Washington,
the State of the Union
is basically their version of...
the Super Bowl.
We started with 32 teams.
Now we're down to the final two.
Kansas City and Philadelphia
are fired up
and ready to fight it out.
One thing's for certain --
they're not...
in love.
Valentine's Day
is less than a week away.
If you don't have
a reservation by now,
you'll be taking your date to...
Taco Bell.
Now, they're offering a new item
called the
Big Ass Mexican Pizza.
If you eat one of those, you're
definitely going to need some...
healthcare.
It's one of the many things
Biden talked about
in his speech.
Democrats loved it,
but Republicans looked...
sick to their stomachs.
That grande Mexican pizza
will do that to you,
but it's the perfect
thing to order
after you finish smoking a...
Super Bowl.
Patrick Mahomes and Jalen Hurts
will be giving their all,
trying their best to...
score.
If you go on a date,
make sure to be a good listener.
Don't just...
talk for an hour straight.
Biden covered a lot --
jobs, the economy,
and our Southern border with...
Mexico.
If you finish the whole pizza,
you can say goodbye to your...
tight end.
In conclusion...
standing O's...
go, team, go...
accept this rose...
por favor, no.
This has been a "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪